manager from Namco Bandai and Mike you
guys are showing off Lords of the Fallen
here today it looks kind of like Dark
Souls but can you tell me a little bit
more about this game yeah it definitely
has some similarities with Dark Souls
obviously we us being Ben and Emma Co
games there's that natural comparison
with Dark Souls but the the game has a
lot of differences too so has a lot of
unique qualities one of them has a very
intriguing storyline so in the game it's
it starts back about 8,000 years ago the
evil god adder has kind of trying to
take over the world humanity was able to
defeat adder and his uh you know lords
which I called back and banished them to
the 'roger dimension since then anyone
that commits any kind of evil sin gets
marked on their face or branded with a
tattoo so for reasons I'm told the evil
God has surfaced again is trying to take
over the world
a icon once again has to defeat the evil
God so they call upon the most evil guy
they could think of which is harken this
guy that has every single sin committed
and mark on his face so it's up to him
to defeat the evil God and the Lords of
the Fallen God which is what they're
called and that's the title so you start
off in that kind of journey he mentioned
there's some RPG elements to this as
well definitely so you have all the
different classes you have a cleric
warrior and rogue cleric seems to be the
favorite today so far but all the skills
all the armor all the weapons are all
interchangeable so full freedom of
customization only magic is bound for a
class so and again there's a lot of
level up there's you get your XP points
you can kind of you know shift things
around right now the guys seem to like
using the warrior sword when there's
going to their inventory but but you
know totally up the the user and show
the weapons or the armor that you find
they change the way that your character
looks as well so you can kind of
customize how you look based on you know
what looks really cool yeah you know the
lighter obviously looks you know not as
BP I guess and then when they get to the
last boss which is the champion Lord my
my style is to go with the light rogue
armor and the rogue daggers because
you're a little bit more nimble and you
can kind of go in and out and kind of
jab at them so but you know some guys go
to the cleric hammer which
massive and it's a it's a little bit
slow but it deals a lot of damage so
it's up to the player and this does not
look like an easy game though I don't I
don't think anyone is going to be or
some people are able to get through it
the first time but you get something
special if you actually make it through
this right you do so what we have here
for a comic-con is the catacombs
challenge so if you know this is a
catacombs level and if you're able to
survive all the way through the
catacombs challenge you get this cool
exclusive shirt with the you know the
the logo and harkens image on the front
that you can see here and then on the
back you have the the hand of God symbol
so it's definitely a cool shirt so far
we've had five people make it through
the challenge so far so how many of you
had play a total it's been I mean you
can see the lines over there there's
constantly people waiting so I don't
know how many people have come through
but I know only five have made it so far
so it's it's challenging but not
punishing you know Dark Souls is very
punishing this game is very challenging
if you're not able to win a t-shirt by
you know making it through the game
there is another chance for you to pick
up something for this game and you guys
have it on display right here that's
right so you know if you feel that you
can't make it all the way through the
catacombs challenge you can also like us
on Facebook for more details to win
Parkins hammer which is the the
favourite weapon of choice today with a
lot of the guys I love the cleric so
it's a life-size replica we'll have it
at San Diego Comic Cons the first place
that we're showing it off at and then
PAX Prime New York Comic Con will also
do the same thing so at the end of Comic
Con well we'll pick a winner and they'll
get this cool hammer life-size replica
but I'm guessing it it doesn't weigh as
much as the actual hammer does actually
pretty heavy though it's not as it's not
as metallic and heavy but it's pretty
it's pretty beefy we also have a harken
a cosplayer walking around too who also
is wielding the hammer so be on the
lookout for him he's got all these sins
mark on his face it's all like tatted up
and and bloodied but but this is
definitely the Harkins hammer challenge
and you know Lords are coming or Harkins
hammer social hashtags very cool and if
you want to see more of Lords of the
Fallen we're gonna have that on our
stage show later this week and stay
tuned to this channel they'll learn more
about comic-con and check out our
sinisterly they just released for
comic-con that just came out today so
well